da liegt sie die insel der götter schön
wie immer ruhig wie nie bali ist in
diesen zeiten so wie im traum eine
idylle ein paradies keine touristen kein
lärm keine party solche bilder liefert
die insel sonst seit jahrzehnten nicht
mehr
aber sonst herrscht er auch kein corona
hoch quer hauptsache junges thema vorne
die gesetze der sozialen medien
erfordern nun mal self auch wenn es
eigentlich auf die kulisse ankommt ab
ins internet damit alle wissen wie es
user auf bali gefällt bali ist zurzeit
wirklich eine traurige in seine lehre im
wegen corona sind nur ganz wenige
indonesische touristen da und praktisch
keine ausländer
die regierung hat uns als influenza
eingeladen unsere fotos und berichte
sollen die menschen motivieren damit sie
bali baldmöglichst wieder besuchen
denn bali braucht die touristen mehr
denn je dafür also legen sie sich ins
zeug
für die botschaft wir lieben bahn eine
gruppenreise von influenza an bloggern
social media akteuren die
tourismusbehörde zahlt sie fotografieren
schreiben posten machen werbung für sich
und für die insel
ich bin autorin und bloggerin
ich füttere meine social media kanäle
mit den interessantesten geschichten und
tipps meine freunde und follower können
dann alles nachverfolgen und am besten
nach machen auf bali das ist die idee
marketing und motivation für die
rückkehr der massen
indonesien hat seine grenzen wegen
corona praktisch dicht gemacht nun
fiebern sie dem tag entgegen an dem die
ausländischen urlauber zurückkehren was
da also jetzt so durchs netz flimmert
wird dem tour organisator rudi gefallen
schon unterwegs wird er die gruppe 1
[Musik]
wir müssen den tourismus dringend wieder
in schwung bringen
wir müssen also unsere botschaft in die
welt schicken dass wir bereit sind die
gene abstand fieber messen
das ist alles vorbereitet alle sollen
wissen dass sie mit den neuen
vorschriften hier sicher sind und das
bali sie willkommen heißt
willkommen zurück denn derzeit ist bali
im tiefschlaf das straßenbild ist
gezeichnet vom scheitern
kuta ist sonst trubel pur manche nennen
es den ballermann für australier aber
australier kommen nicht mehr keiner
kommt mehr rund sechs millionen
touristen fehlen in diesem jahr
hotels sind geschlossen geschäfte zu
knallten dicht rezession herrscht im
ganzen land aber keine region
indonesiens leidet stärker als barney
[Musik]
wird mit ihrem moped heute ganz verloren
auf straßen die sonst unter dichtem
verkehr ächzen die fahrt geht nach gut
noch so ein touristen hotspot hier hatte
moni einen job im schönheitssalon der
laden ist zu
der job ist weg was moni bleibt ist die
hoffnung
[Musik]
die chefin hat gesagt dass sie schnell
wieder öffnen möchte wenn die touristen
zurück kommen sie will dann auch die
angestellten wieder anrufen aber für
alle wird's vielleicht nicht reichen
jeder kann dann vielleicht nur ein paar
tage arbeiten wir müssen abwarten
[Musik]
abwarten aber macht nicht satt
immerhin die familie hat ein feld dessen
ertrag sich moniz man aber mit seinen
drei brüdern teilen muss ein feld also
für vier familien und der reis wächst
leider deutlich langsamer als die sorgen
denn je länger die krise dauert desto
mehr probleme tauchen auf desto
belastender wird die frage wie es
weitergehen soll die schule unserer
kinder ist zu wägen corona für den
online unterricht müssten wir ein
mobiltelefon kaufen und immer neue
datenpakete fürs internet das geld haben
wir aber nicht meine frau kann nichts
mehr dazuverdienen und ich finde auch
keine arbeit und das geht hier also
durchhalten bis es wieder aufwärts geht
die familie lebt von der hand in den
mund und wie so viele andere mit der
hoffnung dass die touristen wiederkommen
und mit ihnen die jobs das geld dafür
werben auch die influenza doch corona
macht den strich durch die rechnung
allen bemühungen zum trotz erlaubt die
regierung die einreise der ausländer
nicht bali muss weiter auf den neustart
warten und setzt dabei auf die kraft der
sozialen medien facebook instagram
youtube alles für bali zumindest für
inländische touristen der influenza john
glaubt das ist der weg aus der krise
für die insel und für ihn selbst ich bin
ja selbst ein opfer der korona krise ich
war koch vor ein paar monaten müsste
mein boss mich entlassen weil keine
gäste mehr ins restaurant kam
auf bali hängt alles an tourismus was
sollst du machen wenn du souvenirs
verkaufs und keine urlauber kommen
wer soll denn erst dann kaufen wovon
kannst du dein leben
es sind schwere zeiten für die insel der
götter ohne touristen die sehnsucht
wächst und bali gibt sich bereit aber es
nützt nichts
derzeit führt kein weg ins paradies
[Musik]